when you first start watching this show
and again I don't want to give anything
too much away but it's a couple that's
going through a really painful period
and then
you as the wife you sort of disappear
from the scene and yeah and she's really
unsympathetic initially I mean we put it
mildly very unsympathetic um and you
don't realize that you're you're seeing
the marriage strictly through a lens you
know the lens you're seeing it through
which is so interesting is uh Jesse
Eisenberg plays uh your husband and of
course Jesse is so good at looking at
being put upon and um I mean I he looks
put upon in real life and a lovely guy
yeah he really is he is one of the
sweetest guys uh but he
he has such a good way of looking like
he's just got the world on his shoulder
that's a really good point you know
because it's true he can flip so easily
from you know a kind of
puppy to you know in this kind of
wounded yeah
um uh you know on his back person to
to a a real villain you know well I mean
you look at the social network yeah and
you see that he's uh he's obviously a
terrific actor who's able to access all
of that yeah but in this
um and I thought they've this show has
exposed either exposed my sexism or or
tricked me into being maybe more sexist
than I already am but yeah I'm really
looking at it and I'm thinking I so
sympathize with this guy this poor guy
and he's trying to take care of these
kids and where is she and
um not being at all sympathetic to your
character and then there's this thing
and again I don't want to give anything
away but there's this scene that uh
where
your character Rachel goes to
this Yoga Retreat and the these emotions
were being drawn out of you in this
scene and you there's this kind of whale
breakdown that you have that like came
through the TV set and slapped me around
in a way that is this is a compliment I
don't like being I'm not into I'm not
into that by the way
not into that no I'm sick of that rumor
that I like being slapped about
um
a whipping occasionally but no uh I felt
like you had reached to the TV and it
was so and then of course I started
talking to my friends who are also
watching the show and we're all talking
about that scene and I think
that scene is the most striking moment I
had in television in memory it just was
like oh my God it completely
turned me around on your character in a
moment but also
I walked away from that thinking
I do not understand I know that there
are great actors in the world I do not
know how Claire Danes was able to do
that I do not know how you were able to
do that scene
well I mean again it was really
re It Was Written yeah you know and I
could I recognized it I find it
unimaginable that you would go to set
and they would put a camera on you and
they would say action and that you'd be
able to I'm basically asking well so so
so in advance I do this this kind of
this mental work and then I have to
totally let that go and then just be in
a visceral right space so I have to be
very clear that and you know and it was
funny when I went to college and didn't
act for about three years I it was a
little uh it was
um I was caught in a raw and the wrong
gear like I forgot that it was largely
an intuitive process also because I had
just been writing essays for a long time
um so I had to kind of return to the
more intuitive connection to the work
which is the more important one right um
but so both are at play and really when
the camera's rolling you have have to
just you know be in a non-thinking space
in the motive space
um but I I and I yeah I I see myself
hear myself
um not like taking maybe it sounds like
I'm not taking credit for my
contributions but I can't do that so
freely if I don't feel held by the
people that I'm working with and John
and Val who are the directors on the
episodes that I was doing the heavy
lifting and um you know they were they
were just so right so connected and
present and kind
um and they didn't make me do things a
million times you know like they
understood that some scenes were a
little scarier and and trickier than
others and so they were very careful and
and how they set it up and you know a
lot of them we only needed to do one
take and I was gonna say if if someone
if a director after the take that you
did said if anyone said okay okay it was
great let's do uh let's do four more
yeah I've also worked with wonderful
directors who do work that way and I you
know I don't
only begrudge them that you know like
sometimes there is value and seeing what
happens and I
um uh but I was glad for their sense of
economy yeah um and and knowing when
they had what they needed
um because I didn't feel like
totally tapped out or exploited or
anything you know I think there is that
that in Vogue there was it got really in
Vogue the improvising especially in
comedies and a lot of improvising and
people being encouraged and now and I
think
um I was on a set once and I there the
the director was literally saying things
like all right try another one where you
are the murderer
now try one where you're the murder
victim like you're changing massive
things do you know what I mean like
right uh yeah but what I do understand
what you're saying that something that
resonates with me because I always try
to look for is there any Common Ground
here I can have with Claire and this is
there might be a psychological reason
for this or it just might be my lack of
ability I don't know what it is but it
was I when I was uh
people were telling me in my early 20s
you've got something you should be in
front of people and I was feeling that
but I couldn't see what it was and it's
like you know it's not stand up I think
it's improv and then one person said it
might help you remember I started doing
improv a lot and someone said just take
a serious
um acting class so I took one downtown
and I don't remember which one it was
but it was like a Stella Adler serious
class and I went in
and signed up and paid I think it was
about 23 24 and there was a they asked
me at one point to do a scene where I
get up with another woman
and I tell her how much I love her
and how much she means to me and how
heartbroken I am
and I said I can do this if it is in the
purpose of being funny ah like if
there's a joke to it I can actually that
would be the only way that I could act I
think in any kind of was if it ends if
it's going in the purpose of a joke
right or if it ends you know that's so
interesting I know and um now you're my
therapist but but but I but I'm serious
like I do I have done sketches where I'm
looking at myself saying I think I'm
kind of here but I it's because I know
that it's in the service of a joke and
to me that's my that's my wooden barrel
I can go over Niagara Falls but I needed
my into be in my wooden barrel of it's
comedy whereas
you know
what you're doing
there's you're going over the falls
there is no Barrel it's so naked and I
find that terrifying I'm in awe of it
but I just find it uh it's terrifying
yeah well I would find comedy terrifying
you know a bit just but I think I I
you're very funny you are really funny
you're a very like no you are you are
very
um
I mean I've always could tell that
you're be a very funny light silly
person at a party and that's something a
lot of people don't know about you yeah
I I guess but I I doubt that that's true
I mean I think you've decided that along
the way and I don't believe it I'm just
saying I also think you're a very good
fighter kickbox I've decided a bunch of
things about you you're also an undersea
Explorer Claire Danes you didn't know
that about yourself did you